Depuis la semaine dernière, je vous ai annoncé que nous sommes en train de considérer la toute dernière section de la lettre de Polo Galate.
Nous avons pris le temps de traverser cette lettre comme il faut, par une série de prédications d'exposition fidèles à la parole.
En fait, on n'est pas faisant de la Bible l'otage du prédicateur assujetti à son propre choix, à son propre enterré, mais en faisant du pasteur et de la communauté des otages des Écritures.
C'est à Dieu de déterminer ce que nous allons écouter les dimanches prochains pour qu'on comprenne bien la parole de Dieu.
Donc on n'a pas traité cette lettre à la légère, on n'a même pas traité verset par verset, on l'a traité parfois mot par mot, expression par expression.
Et c'est tellement riche car la parole de Dieu est inspirée dans son ensemble, mais aussi dans chaque particule.
Et c'est comme ça qu'on doit progresser en permettant Dieu de nous traiter par sa parole.
Quand on arrive donc à la conclusion des conclusions de la lettre des Galates, au verset 11, nous retrouvons, voyez avec quelles grandes lettres je vous ai écrites, déma proprement.
L'apôtre Paul ici, il est très intentionnel à appeler l'attention pour ces faits, car malgré le fait qu'à plusieurs reprises, il utilisait des assistants pour écrire ces lettres, sous sa supervision bien sûr.
Normalement, il portait la signature finale pour authentifier la lettre, pour qu'ils soient sûrs qu'il s'était une lettre, non seulement sous la supervision de Paul, mais même sous sa signature pour préserver surtout l'authenticité apostolique.
Donc, ces ministères exclusifs qui ont compté des douze personnes et qui pour toujours compteront qu'avec douze personnes, un ministère qui ne va plus jamais avoir une réédition,
car ils étaient protégés par Dieu avec cette mission particulière d'être gouvernés par les Saint-Esprits de manière que l'enregistrement de la parole de Dieu soit inhérent et indubitable.
Personne n'aura plus jamais ce type d'autorité.
Donc, lorsqu'il a l'apôtre Paul signé cette lettre, il voulait surtout authentifier cet écrit comme un écrit sacré, comme si Dieu lui-même nous parlait à travers ces lettres.
Mais c'est clair que dans ces passages, il n'est pas tout simplement en train de faire sa signature et ses salutations.
Il est en train de redoubler quelque part toutes les exhortations qui ont marqué la conclusion de la lettre.
Et en le faisant, il va reconnecter sa conclusion à son introduction, comme s'il était en train de vouloir redoubler l'importance et la sévérité de toute la lettre.
Donc, il y a quelques caractéristiques dans cette conclusion qui font de cette conclusion une conclusion unique parmi les épîtres de Paul.
Et qui révèle non seulement l'autorité apostolique, mais surtout les soins pastoraux et même paternels de l'apôtre Paul envers cette communauté.
Donc, il écrit cette conclusion de sa proprement et c'est une conclusion qui sera un peu plus large.
Et donc, ce qu'on a vu la semaine dernière, c'était notamment de considérer l'importance de la forme de cette conclusion.
On était plus concentré car cette conclusion, selon l'avis de la majorité des commentaristes, des experts en Paul,
ils vont dire que c'est l'une des conclusions qui porte le plus pour la compréhension même de toute la lettre.
Si on veut bien comprendre Galate, bien sûr que dans une série d'expositions,
on attend que les pasteurs aient déjà étudié toute la lettre, y compris la conclusion pour vous expliquer toute la lettre.
C'est clair qu'il y avait une intentionnalité particulière de l'apôtre Paul dans cette conclusion
pour redoubler sur l'importance et les enjeux de toute la lettre.
Et donc, c'est important pour nous de considérer que Dieu, il est en train d'inspirer l'auteur de cette lettre,
mais pas sans négliger les contributions personnelles sous sa gouvernance.
Donc, la Bible, elle est glorieuse car nous savons qu'elle est inspirée par Dieu,
mais ce qui fait d'elle encore plus glorieuse, c'est de constater la manière responsable, diligente et authentique.
Donc, les auteurs, ils étaient là, non préoccupés à écrire une lettre ou un texte appréciable dans sa formalité,
un texte précis dans sa théologie, mais un texte qui cherchait à accomplir un but relationnel.
Et donc, la personnalité ou toute la personnalité de l'apôtre Paul est présente,
et pas tout simplement la manière magistrale dont il pourrait écrire,
dont il pourrait suturer un serment.
La manière dont il a été formé en tant que prédicateur et en tant qu'écrivant des lettres bibliques
n'était pas tout simplement toute cette éducation privilégiée qu'il avait eue quand il était à l'école
ou aux écoles dans lesquelles il a étudié, juif, grec, etc.
Et donc, même si nous voyons cette partie qui montre combien brillant l'apôtre Paul est l'été,
dans la manière dont il va suturer cette conclusion et sa lettre,
mais on va voir comment il sait permettre cette liberté qui montre son authenticité.
Très similaire à la manière dont les pharisiens, même, ou les personnes qui écoutaient Jésus disaient,
ils prêchent avec autorité et pas comme les scribes pharisiens.
Donc, jusqu'à aujourd'hui, on peut avoir cette possibilité
de voir des personnes qui ont une très belle rhétorique
et une capacité très précise et appréciable
dans la littérature, des connaisseurs de la littérature
qui vont toujours donner l'impression
d'avoir préparé un serment très appréciable.
Sauf que lorsqu'on sort d'une église
avec la sensation
qu'on est parti
en ayant contemplé un très beau serment,
ça ne sert pas à grande chose.
Il vaut mieux dire en sortant
combien Dieu m'a parlé
qu'il dit
quel beau serment.
Comment Dieu a traité avec moi
plutôt que dire
quel grand prédicateur.
Et c'est comme ça que nous voyons
transparaître
les affections légitimes
de l'apôtre Paul
même s'il fait un usage
très intentionnel de sa suture
pour porter comme un ultimatum
car sa lettre,
même si elle est très suturée
selon les sens ou les termes
de la littérature latine des lettres,
elle est aussi très caractérisée
par les discours grecs
qui avaient cette objectivité
à l'interpellation,
à la transformation,
à communiquer l'autorité de l'orateur.
Et donc nous voyons
dans cette souscription
de l'apôtre Paul
quelques éléments
qu'on trouvait dans toutes les lettres
mais nous voyons plus que ça.
Particulièrement ce que Paul fait
de très intéressant,
c'est de revenir
par les versets 11 à 18
aux enjeux les plus importants
qu'on retrouve
au début de la lettre
dans les chapitres 1
des versets 6 à 10.
Et voilà pourquoi
c'est important
pour la compréhension
de toute la lettre.
Nous allons lire à nouveau
versets 6 à 10
ce qui était
l'introduction
de l'apôtre Paul.
Et donc avec la Bible,
nous apprenons aussi
à préparer un serment
et à prêcher.
La caractéristique
suprême
et particulière
des lettres
poliniennes,
c'est car on était
plutôt devant
une prédication
écrite.
OK ?
Ce n'est pas tout simplement
un traité théologique.
Vous êtes avec moi ?
Et donc ces lettres,
elles étaient déclenchées
par la préoccupation
pastorale,
avec la destinée
éternelle des âmes
du peuple des dieux.
Et donc,
quand on revient
au verset 6 à 10
que nous allons voir
clairement repris
dans sa conclusion
du chapitre 1,
on est devant
l'introduction.
Et ça, c'est aussi
une autre caractéristique
importante
d'un bon serment.
ce qui révèle
un serment
comme un serment authentique,
c'est car dans son introduction,
les prédicateurs
n'est pas préoccupés
à casser
l'ambiance.
Il n'est pas préoccupés
à attirer l'attention
en réduisant
l'intérêt
envers les choses sacrées
à l'intérêt
qu'on pourrait avoir
avec les mondes.
C'est une diminution
de l'importance
des vérités bibliques
lorsqu'on pense
qu'on doit commencer
toujours en serment
avec une anédocte
du quotidien,
de la une,
car la Bible,
elle nous fournit
suffisamment d'exemples,
d'illustrations
et de narratives
en nous apportant
déjà et directement
les enjeux
les plus élevés
qu'on puisse imaginer.
La pertinence
de la Bible,
elle n'a pas besoin
d'être ornée
par la pertinence
des problèmes
de tous les jours
car les problèmes
que la Bible traite
sont des problèmes
beaucoup plus profonds,
beaucoup plus graves,
beaucoup plus pertinents
que ce qu'on pourrait
trouver ailleurs
dans la politique
ou dans les anecdotes
de la vie personnelle
du pasteur.
Et donc l'apôtre Paul,
lorsqu'il fait son introduction,
il va droit au but
et il dit
« Je m'étonne
que vous vous détourniez
si promptement
de celui
qui vous a appelé
par la grâce du Christ
pour passer
à notre évangile. »
Donc remarquez bien,
dès le départ,
l'apôtre Paul,
il n'est pas en train
de rendre
ses discours
en direct.
Son introduction
a pour but
capturé l'attention
des auditeurs.
Donc voilà pourquoi
Lloyd-Jones,
il est tellement
pour
les bonnes introductions,
les introductions
authentiques.
Et parfois,
c'est serment,
c'est presque
la moitié
dédiée à l'introduction
pour montrer
la pertinence,
la relation
interpersonnelle.
Il n'est pas là
en train de prêcher
pour traiter
lui-même
avec les problèmes
du peuple.
c'est pour mettre
les peuples
devant Dieu.
C'est ça
qu'Paul fait
dans son introduction.
Vous êtes en train
de vous détourner,
attention,
de celui
qui vous a appelé.
C'est Dieu lui-même
qui un jour
vous a sauvés.
Et maintenant,
les problèmes
dans cette église,
c'est un problème
pas entre
les faux prophètes
ou les faux apôtres
et l'apôtre Paul.
C'est un problème
entre vous
et Dieu.
OK ?
Et là,
on passe par
la suppression
totale
de la victimisation
du peuple
des dieux.
L'apôtre Paul,
il est en train
de responsabiliser
cette église
car
ils auraient dû
mieux savoir.
Ils savent mieux.
Et donc,
l'essence
de combien graves
étaient les problèmes,
de combien responsables
les peuples étaient,
il est là
depuis le départ.
Donc,
si cette communauté
est une communauté
véritablement chrétienne,
leur attention
est déjà capturée.
Ensuite,
verset 7,
non pas qu'il y ait
un autre évangile,
mais il y a des gens
qui vous troublent
et qui veulent
renverser
l'évangile du Christ.
C'est-à-dire,
vous êtes en train
de passer
du vrai évangile
à un autre,
combien grave,
par contre,
il n'y a pas
un autre évangile.
Donc,
attention
à ces personnes
qui se sont infiltrées
car vous connaissez
les vrais évangiles
et même s'ils peuvent
donner l'apparence
qui c'est pour
votre sanctification,
par leur légalisme,
par leur névrotisme,
faites attention,
il y a
un seul
et vrai évangile.
Donc, attention
au danger.
Parmi vous,
des personnes
qui arrivent
et se présentent
de manière
apparemment très pieuse,
apparemment plus
sans que vous,
c'est possible
qu'ils soient en train
de vous convaincre
que vous devez
filtrer
les moucherons
afin d'avaler
les chameaux
entre vous.
Et donc,
vous devez mieux savoir
et soyez conscient,
l'Église sera toujours
exposée à la présence
des imposteurs
pour mieux qu'elle soit,
pour mieux instruite
qu'elle soit,
même si c'est une Église
implantée par l'apôtre Paul,
qui avait des pasteurs
qui y étaient placés
sous la supervision
de l'apôtre Paul,
c'était une Église
qui était en train
de donner de l'écoute
aux imposteurs
et donc responsabilisation
de l'Église ensuite.
Mais quand nous-mêmes,
ou quand un ange du ciel
annoncera notre évangile,
que celui que nous avons prêché
qu'il soit anathème,
nous l'avons dit précédemment,
je le répète à cette heure,
si quelqu'un vous annonce
notre évangile
que celui que vous avez reçu,
qu'il soit anathème.
Donc, attention,
nous vivons dans une génération
qui nous pousse
à l'écuménisme,
une génération
qui nous pousse
à chercher
à exagérer
dans une miséricorde
détachée
de l'importance
de la vérité.
bien sûr que
le cœur chrétien
doit être prédisposé
à pardonner
à chaque fois
qu'il est devant
de la répentance
authentique.
Par contre,
ce n'est jamais
irresponsable
à point
de devenir vulnérable
à la manipulation
des imposteurs.
la précision
pour les saluts
est déterminante.
Par exemple,
si nous voulons
avoir de l'écuménisme
avec les juifs
ou les judaïsants,
nous sommes en train
de dire
que l'évangile
qui sauve
est un évangile
de Jésus
plus observation
de la loi,
plus performance
personnelle.
Et ça ne peut
sauver personne.
Ce n'est pas
l'évangile.
Donc, attention,
même un évangile
qui semble suggérer
que nous devrions
être encore plus sains,
par d'autres moyens
qu'il influence
de son esprit seul
en Christ et seul,
c'est un faux évangile.
Donc, des fois,
on se dit
mais cette religion
ou cette dénomination
ou ces mouvements
qui reçoivent
les noms des chrétiens
ou plutôt
est-ce qu'on ne devrait
pas au moins
pour être devant
devant la loi
ou devant la société
être vu
comme plus respecté,
est-ce qu'on ne devrait
pas faire partie
de cette association
d'église,
de cette union
de cette famille
d'église ?
Bon, si
au-dedans
de cette association,
il y a
de l'association
entre les vrais
et les faux évangiles,
on ne peut pas
être complice
de ça.
Et donc,
c'est très intéressant
de voir
cet aspect
qui était très
catholique aussi
dans cette réalité.
C'est-à-dire,
à la période
de la réforme,
c'est notamment
pour ça
qu'on a eu
cette scission.
L'intérêt était
de réformer l'église.
Et malheureusement,
comme la présence
catholique
est une présence
plutôt judaïsante,
Christ plus
performance,
plus œuvre,
on a compris
que nous ne pouvons
pas garder
la communion
avec ceux
qui ont tordu
l'évangile
dans son naissance.
Anathème,
selon l'apôtre Paul.
Et donc,
il faut qu'on fasse
attention dans nos jours
aux influences
auxquelles on s'expose.
Et donc,
l'apôtre Paul dit
qu'ils vont apparaître
même comme un ange
de lumière.
Et nous allons voir
comment cela
est répris aussi
dans cette conclusion.
Et maintenant,
et ici,
nous sommes devant
l'épreuve finale
révélatrice
et voilà pourquoi
c'est notamment
ces points-là
sur lesquels
nous allons le plus
nous plonger
dans la conclusion.
Mais c'est-à-dire,
il dit,
maintenant,
est-ce que c'est
la faveur
des hommes
que je désire
ou celle des dieux ?
Est-ce que je cherche
à plaire aux hommes ?
Si j'ai plaisir
encore aux hommes,
je n'essaierai pas
serviteur de Christ.
Donc,
l'apparente vulnérabilité
de l'Église
par rapport
aux leaders
ou aux personnes
qui sont entre nous
et qui cherchent
à nous influencer,
à la possibilité
des imposteurs,
la grande question
qu'on doit se poser,
comment identifier
un vrai ministre du Christ,
un vrai apôtre,
des faux ministres ?
Et ici,
Paul montre la réponse.
Et c'est le test final
qui sera inévitablement
constaté
à long terme.
Et la réalité,
Paul dit,
maintenant,
est-ce que c'est la faveur
des hommes
que je désire
ou celle des dieux ?
Et la grande question,
c'est à qui
veulent plaire
les ministres ?
À qui veulent plaire
les imposteurs ?
Et c'est notamment
sur cette différence
que nous allons nous plonger
dans les contenus
de cette conclusion.
Mais voyez que dès le départ,
dès l'introduction,
nous sommes devant
les exhortations,
les enjeux,
la réalité ou non
de notre foi,
jouer avec l'Évangile,
nous rappeler
de zèle des dieux,
anathème,
condamnation,
sévère,
ultime.
Est-ce que nous voulons
nous retrouver
sous cette malédiction
ou est-ce que nous voulons
nous retrouver
dans les champs
des chrétiens authentiques ?
Voilà pourquoi
Paul va
reprendre
dans sa conclusion
ces mêmes thèmes
qui ont couvert
toute la lettre
et voilà pourquoi
il va redoubler ça
avec
une conclusion particulière.
Je ne vais pas revenir
sur tous les détails,
mais c'est
la conclusion
différente
de la majorité
d'autres conclusions
de l'apôtre Paul
car elles n'ont pas
de salutations finales
ni générales
ni personnelles.
Il ne va pas citer
des noms de personnes
qu'il aime au sein
de cette église,
même s'il aime
des personnes
au sein de cette église
et c'est clair aussi
dans la lettre.
Il ne va pas conclure
avec de l'adoration
car le climat
n'est pas bon,
pas d'action des grâces,
pas de projet
de collaboration
avec cette église.
La réalité,
c'est que la communion
est apparemment
suspendue.
c'est une église
qui était comme
sous une sorte
de discipline
possiblement
définitive
sous la condition
que les vrais chrétiens
de cette communauté
agissent comme telle.
Et c'était notamment
la lettre,
attention,
de la liberté,
la lettre
de l'évangile
de la grâce,
la lettre
de la justification
par la foi seule,
la lettre
qui enlève
toute névrotisation
envers Dieu,
qui veut protéger,
qui veut surtout protéger
une relation filiale
et parentale
avec Dieu,
qui reçoit
les réproches
les plus sévères.
Ce qui prouve
que l'intérêt
de l'apôtre Paul,
c'était l'amour
et la vraie liberté
de cette église.
Et nous devons apprendre
aussi
que si nous ne laissons
pas nous exhorter,
si nous n'aimons pas
les blessures
qui portent la guérison,
il y a peu
d'espoir pour nous
car Dieu
discipline
à ceux qui l'aiment.
Et donc,
cette conclusion,
elle est plutôt
un ultimatum,
une sommation.
Il venait de dire
qu'on ne se moque
pas des dieux.
Et là,
il était en train
de se diriger
directement aux chrétiens.
L'obligation
des tous-croyants
au sein de cette église
de manifester
les fruits de l'esprit,
de suivre la règle
du Christ.
Et ici,
dans la conclusion,
c'est clair
que les exhortations
sont en train
de concerner
surtout les imposteurs
entre eux,
mais elles continuent
d'être dirigées
aux Galates.
Cette lettre
n'a pas été écrite
aux judaïsantes.
Et c'est pour
responsabiliser les Galates
par rapport à la manière
dont ils tolèrent
ou pas
la présence
des imposteurs,
dont ils se laissent
influencer ou pas,
dont,
selon leur propre chair,
ils perçoivent
qu'il y a un intérêt
de la chair en nous
car on n'est jamais
des victimes
totales
des imposteurs.
Combien
de ma chair
est en train
de me pousser
plutôt
à tolérer
cette personne
et me laisser
influencer
par cette personne ?
Et donc,
si Paul
est l'archétype
du vrai chrétien
en tant qu'apôtre,
modèle pour nous,
les judaïsants
sont l'archétype
des imposteurs.
Et la question
pour nous,
c'est
où nous nous retrouvons ?
Et voilà pourquoi
l'intérêt
dans cette conclusion,
passant donc
plutôt au contenu
de cette conclusion
ou de cette forme
qu'on a bien exploité,
l'objectif,
c'est qu'on se laisse
exhorter
pour chercher
à identifier
la distinction
entre la vraie conversion
et la fausse conversion,
les imposteurs
et les vrais chrétiens.
Et donc,
dans ce passage
verset 12,
nous voyons
que c'est vraiment ça
l'objectif des Paul
dans cette conclusion.
Tous ceux
qui veulent
se rendre agréable
selon la chair,
donc regardez
combien fou
c'est la situation
devant laquelle
nous sommes.
Car la grande question
qu'on se pose,
c'est
qu'est-ce que la religion
peut faire avec nous
et qu'est-ce que nous
pouvons faire
de la religion ?
Car quand on pense
des personnes
qui veulent
se plonger
dans la chair,
la chose qu'on se dit,
c'est
les derniers endroits
où cette personne
va se mettre,
c'est dans la religion.
les plus charnelles,
on espère plutôt
les retrouver ailleurs.
Et la crise
quand on est devant
un scandale
ou la révélation
d'un imposteur,
c'est pourquoi ici ?
Pourquoi au milieu
des choses sacrées ?
Pourquoi cette personne
a eu pour but
de s'arrêter
dans un pupitre ?
Et c'est ça
qui est étonnant.
Car même
au sein des églises,
il y a des personnes
qui sont là,
motivées
pour satisfaire
leur désir charnel.
Ils veulent
se rendre
agréables
devant la chair.
Et ensuite,
au verset 14,
Paul dit,
pour ce qui me concerne,
et là,
on va comprendre
que dans les cas
de l'apôtre Paul,
il n'est pas
du tout préoccupé
à la manière
dont il sera
perçu
par les hommes,
par les autres.
il veut
se rendre
agréable
selon l'esprit.
Il veut
se rendre
agréable
devant Dieu.
Son objectif
exclusif,
c'est de
s'accorder
à l'escendal
de la croix
dans la manière
dont il vit
et la manière
dont il proclame
la vérité
que la manière
dont les personnes
vont penser
à propos de lui.
et là,
c'est clairement
tous ceux
qui veulent
d'un côté
se rendre
à l'escendant
à la chair
et de l'autre côté
pour ceux
qui me concernent.
C'est clair
que l'objectif
des Paul ici,
c'est de montrer
clairement
la distinction
entre un imposteur
et un vrai
homme des dieux.
Et donc,
au verset 14,
il dit
« Loin de moi
la pensée
de me glorifier
d'autres choses
qu'il accroît
dans le Seigneur Jésus-Christ
par qui le monde
est crucifié pour moi
comme je suis
pour le monde
car ce n'est rien
d'être circoncis
ou encirconcis,
ce qui est quelque chose
c'est d'être
nouvelle créature. »
Donc,
nous allons
étudier
bien
comment
nous pouvons
identifier
attention,
ça c'est très important,
très précis,
un homme des dieux
et un imposteur.
Sauf que
lorsque nous serons
en train d'observer
ces caractéristiques,
à la fin des comptes,
on doit se rappeler
que nous ne sommes pas
devant une personne
qui est en train
de vivre
de cette manière
l'authentique
comme si ça
c'était le résultat
de ses propres efforts.
L'emphase
de l'apôtre
pour la fin des comptes
c'est
c'est impossible
de vivre
pour la croix du Christ,
c'est impossible
de vivre
afin de plaire
Dieu seul
et non les hommes,
c'est impossible
de ne pas vivre
préoccupé
avec les apparences
si on n'a pas été
objet
d'un miracle
qui a totalement
changé
notre nature.
circoncision
ou non
aucune chose
ce qui importe
nouvelle création.
Et donc
nous allons
bien
contempler
les caractéristiques
de l'imposteur
et de l'authentique
en nous rappelant toujours
qu'à la fin des comptes
nous ne serons
qu'en train
de constater
la réalité.
sauf que
dans les cas
des imposteurs
bien sûr
ils saillent
constamment
de faire semblant
et nous allons donc
être attentifs
à ces subtilités.
Donc la vérité
centrale pour nous
c'est que Paul
vise à communiquer
dans cette dernière section
c'est que
les tests
ultimes
de la réalité
de la foi
authentique
ou d'une nouvelle création
est une vie
qui se glorifie
exclusivement
dans la croix
de notre Seigneur
Jésus Christ.
Les scandales
de la croix
de notre Seigneur
Jésus Christ.
Et la question
clé pour nous
c'est
quelles sont
les épreuves
d'une vie
qui se glorifie
exclusivement
en Jésus Christ.
Dans ces passages
Paul va faire
une opposition
entre les imposteurs
les hypocrites
et la foi
authentique.
Et quelles sont
donc les preuves
de quelqu'un
ou d'une vie
qui se glorifie
en Jésus seul
et dans sa croix.
La première réponse
que nous allons
considérer
elle s'ébase
sur les versets 11
que nous allons
bientôt lire à nouveau
c'est qu'une vie
qui se glorifie
réellement
dans la croix
du Christ
manifeste
une affection
authentique
pour Christ
pour son peuple
et pour son évangile.
pendant
que de l'autre côté
les hypocrites
peuvent même
dissimuler
de l'affection
mais ils sont
surtout
motivés
ou présentent
plutôt
un faux soin
car ils ont
des intérêts
personnels.
Et donc là
nous sommes dans
un champ
très subtil
mais un champ
dont la Bible
parle énormément.
Donc les versets 11
est une manifestation
claire,
évidente,
explicite
d'une caractéristique
des lettres
pauliniennes
que nous voyons
partout.
L'apôtre Paul
pour plus brillant
et plus structuré
qu'il soit
en tant qu'écrivant
à plusieurs reprises
va couper
même son fil
d'argumentation
car il va
exploser
envers
la préoccupation
les ailes
ou exploser
envers
l'adoration.
Quand on lit
la lettre au roman
on ne peut pas
s'empêcher
de contempler ça
surtout dans la transition
de la fin du chapitre 11
envers les débuts
du chapitre 12.
Ce sont presque
dix chapitres
pour nous convaincre
théologiquement
et pour donner
des évidences
empiriques
de la vraie vie
que même
les mieux
des juifs
selon la chair
n'ont pas la capacité
de garder la loi
et donc nous sommes
tous serrés
dans la condamnation.
tous misérables
et là il va exploser
car Dieu a tous serrés
dans la condamnation
afin
d'utiliser
de la grâce
de la miséricorde
avec beaucoup
et là il va exploser
en adoration
en parlant
de l'infinie
richesse
de Dieu
qu'il a instruit
d'abord
pour recevoir
quelque chose
et donc il va adorer
il va couper
son argumentation
et ici nous voyons
de manière très claire
verset 11
comme s'il avait
pris la lettre
de la main
de cet amanuance
et qu'il a dit
ok la lettre
elle est super
peut-être
mais là
il faut mettre
l'emphase
il faut que
je montre
mon affection
elle est remplie
des termes
qui ont pour objectif
sécouer ses auditeurs
donc les émotions
les affections
elles doivent être là
dans la vraie foi
si elles ne sont pas là
il n'y a pas la vraie foi
en même temps
les affections
doivent être proportionnelles
au sujet
qu'on touche
parfois
la maturité
fait le travail
pour qu'on puisse
se maîtriser
et parfois
une maîtrise
des soins exagérés
sonne plutôt
comme
une foi hypocrite
l'absence
d'affection
les pasteurs
de l'église
où je me suis converti
à l'époque
ils racontaient
à chaque fois
cette histoire
où au début
de sa foi
peut-être par manque
de maturité
ou de maîtrise
au début
de son ministère
un jour
il a monté
sur les premiers rangs
il a commencé
à prêcher
il disait
j'avais envie
de sécuer chacun
et c'est vraiment
la sensation
qu'on devrait voir
quand on est en train
de parler
du destin éternel
de vos âmes
et donc ici
la première
les premiers termes
qu'il utilise
c'est
voyer
ça montre
qu'il veut
s'assurer
d'une attention
proportionnelle
à la gravité
des choses
qu'il est en train
de dire
dans la lettre
c'est
peut-être
qu'il imagine
comme il est habitué
aussi à prêcher
que pendant qu'il est
en train
de parler
des choses
graves
lourdes
importantes
belles
glorieuses
certains sont
en train
de s'endormir
certains sont
plutôt en train
de penser
à d'autres
mais lui
c'est comme
s'il voulait
sécouer
la personne
voyée
ce n'est pas ça
que Jésus fait
quand il raconte
la parabole
des terrains
la première
sémence
qui tombe
au bord
du schéma
que les oiseaux
viennent
et volent
quelle est la raison
il y a
une responsabilité
par rapport
à l'écoute
d'un message
si important
si sacré
si pertinent
qui révèle
où est le cœur
de l'auditeur
même si
la régénération
est nécessaire
pour la vraie
conversion
nous sommes
responsabilisés
parce que nous
rejetons l'évangile
c'est un mystère
et c'est notamment
ça que les seigneurs
Jésus
ont enseigné
de cette parabole
ils ne sont pas
en train de donner
les mieux
du terrain
de leur cœur
à la parole
ils ne sont pas
en train de donner
les mieux
de leur attention
au message
de l'évangile
ils sont en train
de traiter
l'évangile
comme
périphérique
par rapport
à ses valeurs
à sa vie
et Paul
comme il aime
ses auditeurs
il va dire
voyez
responsabilisation
des auditeurs
en tant qu'apôtre
voyez
veut dire
c'est l'ultimate
si Dieu
a décidé
dans sa providence
qui est dans cette période
de vos vies
vous soyez exposés
comme moi
à ses exhortations
c'est comme si Paul
avait fait
les mieux
de son travail
avec cette lettre
qu'il va conclure
en disant
d'ici vers l'avant
vous avez été exhorté
je n'ai jamais été complice
de votre paresse
spirituelle
de votre léthargie
de votre inconstance
de votre mépris
de la manière
dont vous êtes en train
de vous moquer
des dieux
maintenant
je vous secoue
une dernière fois
considérez
qu'à partir d'ici
c'est les ailes
des dieux
enflammées
sur vous
vous voyez
avec
quelle grande lettre
donc
soin
paternel
autorité
apostolique
avec
quelle grande lettre
donc c'était
une lettre
donc il ne pourrait pas
comme nous pouvons
aujourd'hui
envoyer un message
vocal
mais si
on était en train
d'écouter
les messages
vocales
de l'apôtre Paul
par cette lettre
on allait constater
l'emphase
qu'il est en train de mettre
avec
quelle grande lettre
emphase
tonalité
ce qui ne peut
jamais être
absent
dans une prédication
légitime
où les pasteurs
aiment vraiment
les peuples
où les pasteurs
a vraiment
la conscience
qu'il va rendre
compte devant Dieu
c'est impossible
de ne pas être
enflammé
parfois
c'est aussi
très hypocrite
parfois
quand on est en train
de voir une personne
crier
pour rire
juste par habitude
par contre
si la
prédication
est toujours
monotonique
les affections
n'oscillent pas
à la proportion
de thèmes
de sujets
on doit se demander
si c'est une prédication
publique
on n'est pas là
pour essayer
d'adapter
la prédication
à la manière
dont notre culture
européenne
française
a appris
à apprécier
les discours
publics
politiques
car la parole
des dieux
ne fait pas appel
tout simplement
à la raison
elle fait appel
aux affections
avec
quelles
grandes lettres
peut-être
on dirait
Paul est un peu
démodé ici
un peu
hors contrôle
ce qui est intéressant
c'est que
comme c'est enregistré
et comme
ces lettres
devraient être
lues
aux églises
elles circulaient
entre les églises
ce n'est pas intéressant
de voir
qu'intentionnellement
il écrit
car il sait
que la personne
qui est là
entendait lire
devraient trembler
car il voit
les grandes lettres
mais l'apôtre Paul
écrit
voyez avec
quelles
grandes lettres
c'est-à-dire
son intérêt
n'était pas
tout simplement
que les lecteurs
reçoivent
l'impact
de cette exhortation
mais qu'il soit sûr
que toute la communauté
soit au courant
qu'il est en train
d'écrire
avec
grandes lettres
car ça
vous concerne
ça nous concerne
à tous
ensuite il va dire
je vous ai écrit
donc avec
quelles grandes lettres
je vous ai écrit
et ça
montre
la réalité
de la proximité
à nouveau
apostolique
car
Galate
comme les autres
églises
était pour Paul
comme
les sceaux
de son apostolat
cet évangile
qui a pénétré
les excrémités
de la terre
les mondes paillants
et qui a produit
si tant de fruits
était la preuve
de la part des dieux
qui Paul
était un vrai apôtre
la puissance
de l'évangile
qui va pénétrer
les religions
les plus paillantes
et qui va rendre
les paillants
qui avant
étaient promiscus
qui étaient considérés
par les religieux
juifs
comme
les pires
des pécheurs
par leur habitude
par leur
même loi
parfois
par leur idolâtrie
par leur manière
de s'habiller
de parler
et ils retrouvaient
cette génération
ces mondes anciens
ont pu retrouver
en Galatie
au début
de leur foi
entre les philippiens
des personnes
qui n'ont jamais
eu un arrière-plan
religieux
et qui étaient
évidemment
plus sans
que les juifs
les plus religieux
et donc
l'apôtre Paul
il est en train
d'écrire
avec conscience
qu'il est
pour cette église
l'apôtre
donc il écrit
dans la position
d'apôtre
en avertissant
mais il écrit
aussi comme
père spirituel
moi-même
je vous ai écrit
et ça c'est intéressant
l'équilibre
entre l'authenticité
de la relation
l'accessibilité
au pasteur
cette personnalité
chaleureuse
contraire
à un serment
ou une lettre
froide
un exposé théologique
Paul
différent
des faux apôtres
il n'est pas en train
de faire
usage
des méthodes
des sutures
il n'est pas en train
de développer
au sein de l'église
une espèce
des disciples
là
où nous pouvons
tous adopter
la même moule
et n'importe qui
peut faire
le travail
avec les autres
on n'est pas
complètement
réfratère
ou contraire
aux méthodes
à quelques repères
mais nous devons
être toujours
sensibles
à l'interaction
interpersonnelle
savoir identifier
où la personne
elle est
dans sa foi
quel remède
dans toute la Bible
appliquée
à cette situation
présente
c'est à dire
que
dans les systèmes
judaïsants
juifs
c'était facile
de devenir
un imposteur
car on pourrait
faire usage
des méthodes
et des apparences
donner l'impression
des présences
mais être distant
et des fois
c'est comme ça
qu'on voit
la fausse affection
pour les peuples
des dieux
car ça donne
l'impression
d'un intérêt
pour mon bien
pour ma sainteté
mais ça garde
une distance
incroyable
derrière
la position
l'autorité
Paul
lorsqu'il dit
j'écris
moi-même
il est en train
de dire
bien que je suis
distant
comme il a écrit
au Corinthien
mon esprit
est avec vous
j'arrive pas
à dormir
comme il dit
en plus
de toutes les souffrances
que j'ai vues
pour l'évangile
il y a quelque chose
qui pèse sur moi
c'est les soins
ou les préoccupations
avec toutes les églises
qui tombent
que je ne brûle
l'authenticité
de cette relation
personnelle
de l'apôtre Paul
avec cette église
et même envers
des églises
qu'il n'a même
pas implanté
mais nous voyons
cette affection
que l'apôtre Paul
est en train
de manifester
lorsqu'il dit
j'ai moi-même
vos écrits
c'est pour qu'il se rappelle
de quelle manière
Paul était entre eux
au départ
vous vous rappelez
quand on a passé
par ça
avec la lettre
il avait été lapidé
juste avant
d'arriver en Galassie
il était presque mort
il a insisté
il a continué son voyage
il a prêché
et les Galates
ont reçu l'apôtre Paul
comme si c'était un ange
comme si c'était Jésus
lui-même
étant même prédisposé
à lui donner
leurs propres yeux
c'est-à-dire
ils avaient reconnu
l'amour d'épaule
et qu'ils étaient
devant un ange
et maintenant
ils sont en train
de se laisser porter
par l'influence
des imposteurs
ils sont en train
de régner
l'authenticité
de leur affection
pour les vrais apôtres
pour les vrais
évangiles
la manière irresponsable
dont ils sont en train
d'accueillir
les faux enseignements
est en train
de révéler
s'ils ont jamais
eu des vraies affections
pour Dieu
pour l'évangile
pour les hommes
des dieux
ou
si leur affection
aujourd'hui
elle est
cautérisée
dormante
mais Paul
même distant
il est très bien présent
et le problème
c'est que parfois
les pasteurs
de nos jours
même présents
ils sont très distants
on n'a pas
d'accessibilité
à leur vie
à leur traitement personnel
mais non seulement
cet effort
pour que Paul
rappelle à ces personnes
c'est moi-même
qui vous ai cru
pardon
mais il dit
déma proprement
et là il faut aller
encore une couche
plus loin
car nous pouvons aussi
à cause des valeurs
culturelles
des habitudes
nous cacher
derrière
la manière
conventionnelle
de se porter
mais il y a
certains types
de relations
qui devraient
dépasser
ce qui est conventionnel
je me rappelle
qui est
l'une des choses
qui nous a
plus étonné
dans un cas
ici en France
c'était une rencontre
où Mayra
a fait
un voyage
de travail
et c'était
dans la ville
d'un de ses collègues
et il y a eu
cette rencontre
avec ses parents
et quand ils
se sont retrouvés
après plusieurs
mois
sans se voir
ils ont tout simplement
serré la main
et ses soins-ci
pour dîner
et ça peut
pénétrer
ou impréguer
presque la totalité
des relations
père-enfant
et nous ne pouvons pas
négliger que ce n'était
pas toujours comme ça
même dans cette culture
et on ne peut pas
négliger non plus
que ça peut être lié
avec cette manière
irresponsable
dont on va dire
on ne veut pas
interférer
dans la vie
de nos enfants
fruit de la
postmodernité
et de garder
cette relation
froide
et distante
même dans
l'environnement
familial
par contre
dans la Bible
même la relation
de la famille
de la foi
est marquée
par une proximité
plus profonde
et plus légitime
la Bible nous parle
de ses
de ses salutations
saintes
des proximités
Paul il écrit
de sa proprement
donc
ça porte la notion
du sérieux
mais bien sûr
que ça porte
la notion
de la proximité
voilà pourquoi
on doit être encouragé
même lorsqu'on est en train
de corriger
ou discipliner nos enfants
pour plus difficile
que ça soit
qu'on les fasse
toujours dans
l'encadrement
de l'amour
il faut que l'amant
qui corrige
parfois
soit
surtout
l'amant
qui embrasse
avec beaucoup plus
de constance
et donc là
on voit
de manière très claire
comment l'apôtre
Paul
il nous rappelle
quelle est la culture
biblique
du ciel
quelle devrait être
la culture
pour nous
en tant que chrétien
le niveau
des proximités
affectives
en toute pureté
je pense qu'il n'y a pas
besoin de dire ça
mais en toute pureté
donc si d'un côté
on voit l'apôtre
Paul
qui manifeste
ses affections
de manière très claire
de l'autre côté
nous voyons
la possibilité
de l'exhortation
biblique
très généreuse
envers
la fausse émotion
il y a un ouvrage
de Jonathan Edwards
si quelqu'un peut m'aider
avec les titres en français
c'est l'oeuvre
du Saint-Esprit
quelque chose comme ça
Religious Affections
dans l'original
où il nous aide
à identifier
les vraies affections
spirituelles
c'est une lecture
obligatoire
on ne peut pas passer
de l'autre côté
du jour dense
sans avoir lieu
et quand on va
dans la Bible
on a plusieurs possibilités
lorsque Jésus
va conclure
les sermons
sur la montagne
en disant
au chapitre 7
ceux qui me disent
Seigneur, Seigneur
n'entreront pas tous
dans les royaumes
des cieux
mais celui-là
seul qui fait
la volonté de mon Père
qui est dans les cieux
lorsque la Bible
a dit
Seigneur, Seigneur
dans la culture hébraïque
juive
c'est toujours
pour mettre en phase
sur l'affection
les émotions
la répétition
elle vise à communiquer
de l'affection
et ce sont des personnes
qui étaient des imposteurs
mais qui arrivaient même
à dire
Seigneur, Seigneur
publiquement
on voit aussi
lorsqu'il peut
l'écrit
à Timothée
qu'il fasse attention
car la motivation
de l'apôtre Paul
donc les buts
du commandement
c'est une charité
ou un amour
venant d'un cœur pur
d'une bonne conscience
et d'une foi
sincère
car la manifestation
apparente de l'amour
peut venir
d'un cœur double
manipulateur
d'une conscience
cautérisée
et d'une foi
qui n'est pas sincère
ensuite
en Romain chapitre 12
verset 9
il dit
que l'amour soit
sans hypocrisie
remarquez bien
les besoins
absolus
des affections
religieuses
chez les chrétiens
que l'amour
soit sans hypocrisie
ayez les mâles
en erreur
on est poussé
parfois
à utiliser
d'une espèce
très légère
des miséricordes
des compassions
sans voir
des signes évidents
de répentance
car les imposteurs
ils manipulent
jusqu'au là
les imposteurs
au sein de l'église
surtout
ils ont été
tellement habitués
à comprendre
les mécanismes
de l'évangile
les méthodes
religieuses
qu'ils peuvent utiliser
tous les mots
qui auraient pu
nous convaincre
nous donner l'impression
qu'on est obligé
à pardonner
à nouveau
à la légère
sauf que si cette personne
ne manifeste pas
l'abroration
l'horreur
envers les péchés
dans lesquels
il est tombé
si les signes
de répentance
ne sont pas
convaincre
il n'y a pas
de la contrition
si les larmes
ne sont pas
proportionnelles
car les larmes
peuvent être là
même avec
les aïe
surtout quand il se voit
devant les conséquences
pour sa réputation
ou
d'avoir perdu
la possibilité
de continuer
à manipuler
ayez les mal
en erreur
il ne suffit pas
de faire une liste
des péchés
et les confesser
comme faisaient
les catholiques
avec les confessionnaires
et d'essayer
de compenser ça
avec les indulgences
qu'est-ce que je dois
faire maintenant
réponse biblique
Joël
déchirez vos cœurs
et non
vos vêtements
pas l'apparence extérieure
ayez les mal
en erreur
attachez-vous
fortement au bien
évidence
des réelles répentances
Pierre est arrivé
même
à nier
les Christs
mais ce n'est pas
devenu une pratique
récourante
dans sa vie
il a eu
erreur
de ces mal
qu'il a pratiqué
et toute sa vie
a été marquée
notamment par son
accrochage
au bien
par amour fraternel
lisez avec moi
roman 12
verset 10
par amour fraternel
soyez
plein
d'affection
les uns pour les autres
plein d'affection
bien sûr
que pour cela
il faut d'abord
aimer authentiquement
Dieu
pour aimer son peuple
car Dieu nous appelle
à aimer
une église
qui est en cours
des réparations
elle n'est pas
toujours aimable
mais il faut que cet amour
soit un amour
rempli d'affection
séparé du temps
pour passer
avec vos frères et sœurs
afin de progresser
en amour
plein d'affection
les uns pour les autres
par honneur
osé
des prévenances
réciproques
ne soyez pas
vulnérables
aux imposteurs
prévenances réciproques
dès que vous voyez
les risques
de péché
les dangers
agissez
pour vous protéger
les uns
envers les autres
prévenez-vous
les uns
les autres
par rapport
aux imposteurs
découverts
entre vous
prévenances
réciproques
par honneur
osé
des prévenances
réciproques
verset 11
en termes remplis
d'affection
dans son essence
dans sa compréhension
ayez du zèle
et non de la paresse
pourquoi on ne voit pas
plus des disciplines
pratiquées
dans les églises
comme elles devraient
être pratiquées
paresse des pasteurs
combien du travail
ça donne
une fois on m'a dit
à chaque fois
que tu viens
me demander du conseil
pour traiter
les cas pastoraux
on a l'impression
que les cas
les plus compliqués
retombent toujours
sur vous
mais la grande question
pour moi
dans mon cas
c'est est-ce que
les pasteurs
sont en train
de poser
les bonnes questions
car à plusieurs reprises
on ne préfère
même pas poser
de questions
quand on va recevoir
des nouveaux membres
quand on va traiter
un cas pastorale
on préfère
rester dans la surface
mais ça veut
non seulement
pour les pasteurs
mais pour toute la communauté
chercher
d'avoir les ailes
pour la vie
de ton frère
et ta soeur
comme tu devrais
voir pour toi
chercher
à encourager
de manière
diligente
à ses ailes
soyez
fervent d'esprit
quelle était
la dernière fois
où vous avez eu
un moment
d'adoration
à l'église
ou chez vous
dans votre chambre
cachée
en priant
avec ferveur
en lisant
la Bible
avec le coeur
qui brûle
soyez fervents
d'esprit
servez
les seigneurs
et bien sûr
cette exhortation
des aïe
qui est toujours là
je dois faire court
mais
la Bible nous présente
au moins
quatre cas graves
des fausses
affections religieuses
la première
c'est l'apathie
ou l'absence
d'affection
on est en train
d'adorer Dieu
et les vérités
bibliques
glorieuses
nous sont présentées
et la réponse
la réponse
n'est pas proportionnelle
à la gloire
de Dieu révélé
de l'évangile
la personne
elle peut aller
regarder les matchs
du PSG
à l'estade de France
au parc des princes
pardon
crier
sauter des joies
pleurer
parfois
on ne l'a jamais vu
faire les mêmes
en réfléchissant
au destin éternel
de son âme
combien de sacrifices
il peut faire
combien de générosité
pour acheter
un symbole
de la tri parfois
si cher qu'il est
les sacrifices
on ne voit pas
les mêmes efforts
pour la sanctification
pour l'évangélisation
on réproche beaucoup
et bien sûr
il y a beaucoup
d'aberrations
on arrivera
nos frères charismatiques
légitimes
il y en a beaucoup
et ils ont
une affection
extraordinaire
authentique
aussi pour les seigneurs
parfois
les gloires à Dieu
alléluia
sont déplacées
parfois
c'est plus par habitude
que par
réaction légitime
à la vérité
à Christ
mais comme
quelqu'un a déjà dit
il vaut mieux
si je ne me trompe
pas c'est espoir
les bruits
de la maternité
qui est le silence
du sémitière
et donc
absence d'affection
pour les choses
spirituelles
est un signe
avertissant
et grave
d'hypocrisie
religieuse
mais il y a aussi
cette dissimulation
des affections
on peut penser
dans plusieurs passages
bibliques
comme les prières
publiques
des pharisiens
ces passages
de Matthieu 7
où il dit
seigneur, seigneur
ou pendant
qu'il faisait les jeunes
et qu'il présentait
un visage
attristé
la pleure
des Judas
ou la pleure
des Ahus
et nous pouvons
voir comment
nous pouvons
être devant
la dissimulation
des affections
une apparence
extérieure
des piétés
mais les cœurs
il est loin
des dieux
et on voit
les théâtres
la rhétorique
les calculs
ils adorent
avec les lèvres
mais les cœurs
sont absents
les cœurs
n'est pas là
et parfois
on identifie
comment ces choses
sont en constante
sont décrochées
sont déplacées
dans l'histoire
de l'église
on a eu cet épisode
avec Luther
où William Tetzel
pourrait même
faire un théâtre
en brûlant
sa proprement
afin d'extraire
de l'argent
du peuple
pour délivrer
l'âme du purgatoire
les moments
les moments où
la pièce
touche au fond
du peau
une âme
est libérée
du purgatoire
et voilà pourquoi
on doit être
vraiment
attentif
aux possibilités
de la dissimulation
entre nous
donc Lloyd Jones
il raconte
l'histoire
d'un prédicateur
itinérant
qui était très apprécié
et lui-même
l'appréciait
à un moment donné
une personne
lui raconte
qu'elle voulait
suivre ses prédications
il l'appréciait
dans un endroit
et par coïncidence
il serait aussi
la semaine prochaine
dans les mêmes endroits
où cette personne
allait apprécier
à nouveau
et il raconte
que
c'était presque
parfaitement calculé
les moments
où
ses prédicateurs
s'arrêtent
sur un point
et il dit
quels seraient
les mots
les plus appropriés
pour utiliser
maintenant
et qu'il touche
sa tête
il réfléchit un peu
et il dit
je sais
et il utilise
ces mots
et la semaine prochaine
il fait exactement
la même chose
dans les prochains séons
dissimulation
recours rhétorique
et voilà pourquoi
pour Lloyd Jones
c'était presque abominable
dans la formation
des prédicateurs
de simuler
les prédications
ou de s'efforcer
trop
sur la rhétorique
il faut que ça soit
toujours authentique
que ça soit toujours
réel
vivant
impostation des voix
!
et donc c'est clair
que ni tous les pasteurs
seront les plus
enflammés
dans leur tempérament
dans leur
émotion
mais c'est clair
que même dans
les cadres
de chaque tempérament
il faut qu'on
identifie
la réalité
car il faut aussi
qu'on ne dissimule
pas non plus
dans l'autre sens
après en prédication
comme celle-ci
on est tellement
peureux
de dissimuler
l'affection
et de donner
une impression
d'une fausse
humilité
quand on prie
parfois
on va se dire
si
je manifeste
plus d'émotion
les personnes
vont penser
que je suis
en train de
dissimuler
si je manifeste
pas
les personnes
vont penser
que je suis
apathique
donc je préfère
ne plus prier
jamais
car je serai jugé
c'est pas ça
l'objectif
l'objectif c'est
de vivre la foi
authentique
devant Dieu
ça sera perçu
c'est même
en public
prier
encaché
dans ma chambre
intérieure
c'est de me voir
devant Dieu
seul
chercher à plaire
Dieu seul
et cette authenticité
sera vue
elle n'est pas
calculée
elle ne peut pas
être cachée
il y a aussi
le danger
de l'émotionalisme
l'émotion
par l'émotion
les plaisirs
dans l'émotion
la version
gospel
des mantras
ésotériques
les néo-charismatismes
répétition
jusqu'à ce qu'on rentre
dans une espèce
d'extase
un vernis religieux
mais les cœurs
partagés
entre Dieu
et le monde
qu'est-ce qui déclenche
mon émotion
mon affection
quand je suis
dans un environnement
qui m'encourage
constamment
à manifester
les émotions
la première question
qu'on doit se poser
c'est
qu'est-ce qui déclenche
les émotions
est-ce que ce qui déclenche
mes émotions
c'est véritablement
la connaissance
relationnelle
d'une vérité glorieuse
car c'est impossible
de savoir
que j'étais réconcilié
avec les dieux
de l'univers
les dieux glorieux
la source
de tout bonheur
et n'est pas sauter
des joies
c'est impossible
de voir la présentation
du Christ placardé
comme crucifié
à ma place
et n'est pas crié
gloire à Dieu
alléluia
c'est impossible
de voir l'état
courant des choses
et n'est pas
souplié
Maranatha
revient
Seigneur Jésus
on est en train
de parler
des termes
et des langages
bibliques
c'est pas pour rien
que parce que
tous les psaumes
nous exhortent
à sauter des joies
à louer
car il va
bien avec Dieu
de les louer
ça doit être déclenché
par la vérité
par la relation
avec Dieu
et parfois
on a l'impression
qu'il s'est déclenché
par les promesses
vides
de la théologie
de la prospérité
on est plutôt là
en train de manifester
plein d'émotions
car nos affections
sont dirigées
envers
la maison
qu'on attend recevoir
ou les mariages
qui n'est pas encore arrivé
et donc
mon attachement terrestre
provoque
plus d'affection
en moi
que ce que j'ai déjà
en Jésus Christ
et parfois
c'est tout simplement
l'ego supprimé
dans la société
car si
dehors
Dieu est satisfait
même avec
celui qui entend
d'enlever
les laits de la vache
comme disaient
les réformateurs
il est fait pour la gloire
de Dieu
il sait que Dieu
a les plaisirs dans sa vie
pour plus simple
qu'il soit sa tâche
Dieu
il est en train de voir
qu'il est fait avec excellence
pour la gloire de Dieu
peu importe ce qu'on fait
un chrétien est satisfait
peu importe
qu'il soit les lots
réservés pour lui
aujourd'hui
par contre
on va parfois
dans des cercles
religieux chrétiens
soi-disant chrétiens
où
cet ego
dévalorisé
dans la société
supprimé
manque de valeur
devant les hommes
essaye d'être compensé
dans l'environnement
de l'église
une position
une réputation
un éloge
et cette position
donne à cette personne
une espèce
d'extravation
pour extravaser
ses émotions
supprimées
tout le temps
et des fois
on voit comment
en arrivant
à certaines églises
on voit
plein de manifestations
d'émotions
sans que ces émotions
soient
enracinées
dans la parole
de Dieu
dans la vérité
les fondements
n'est pas en Dieu
et c'est clair
que des fois
on va
contempler
les affections
évidemment
opposées à Dieu
comme les démons
dont Jacques
nous parle
dans les chapitres 2
car même
les démons
ont de l'affection
mais c'est la peur
la terreur
des dieux
et des choses divines
les affections
que Judas
a démontrées
en faisant semblant
qu'il avait
de la peine
pour les pauvres
mais il volait
l'argent
certains qui
vont nous dire
qu'on ne devrait
absolument pas
consommer
aucune chose
du monde
de la grâce commune
mais on ne sait pas
ce qu'ils sont en train
de faire en cachette
qu'ils sont en train
de trier les moustiques
pour avaler les chamons
la dissimulation
qui révèle constamment
plutôt l'abomination
pour les choses divines
on est en train
d'avoir une conversation
théologique
où un ami
non chrétien
est entre nous
la conversation
commence
à se diriger
à la possibilité
de partager
l'évangile
et la personne
sans percevoir
coupe la conversation
en posant une question
professionnelle
à la personne
où on est en train
d'avoir des échanges
importants
sur Dieu
sur la foi
l'intérêt par exemple
de l'état
de l'église
dans les mondes
et la personne
elle décroche
la conversation
car ça ne l'intéresse pas
elle n'a pas d'affection
pour les choses de Dieu
pour les peuples de Dieu
pour les cieux sacrés
donc soit l'apathie
soit
une espèce
de manifestation
claire
que l'intérêt
est ailleurs
par contre
on voit clairement
dans la vie
de l'apôtre Paul
ses désirs
de plaire
Christ seul
et n'est pas
calculé
on voit
la prise
des risques
on voit
comment l'évangile
est en train
d'impréguer
et on voit
surtout
que l'authenticité
des affections
elle se montre
par sa constance
il peut être
très affectionné
dans les poupîtres
et pour les peuples
des dieux
dans les poupîtres
par contre
on va déjeuner
chez lui
on voit la manière
dont il traite
son épouse
avec quelle distance
avec quelle apathie
ou envers
les publics
il est très cordial
envers tous
pour les publics
dans les poupîtres
il parle
de l'amour
des dieux
l'amour
pour les peuples
et l'amour
pour les perdus
et dès qu'il rentre
dans un resto
il va traiter
les serveurs
de manière
très arrogante
et dure
donc la constance
doit être là
la proportion
au thème
à la situation
la vraie prédication
elle est toujours
née
des deux éléments
la lecture
constante
de la bible
en esprit
de prière
relation avec Dieu
et contact
avec les peuples
des dieux
amour
affection
car c'est impossible
d'arriver
sur un poupître
en étant
un prédicateur
authentique
et de ne pas
déborder
d'affection
et d'amour
si on est en contact
avec Dieu
constamment
et avec son peuple
bien-aimé
donc une vie
qui se glorifie
réellement
dans la croix
manifeste
une affection
authentique
pour Christ
son évangile
et son peuple
pas
un faux soin
intéressé
envers la religion
Amen
nous allons prier